crystal viewers only see the two to
three minute reports you put together
during your coverage on the war in
ukraine but obviously there's a lot more
surrounding that experience before even
landing in ukraine what work has to take
place to get you there safely it's a lot
of research it's a lot of chatting with
people and making sure that you know the
situation on the ground and you're sort
of staying on top of everything because
you can do as much preemptive work as
you want to but it can change by the
minute so it's just continuously staying
on top of as much information as
possible and then trying to sort through
what's the good information and and
what's not it's generally you and a
camera operator on the ground but i know
it's a much bigger team that deals with
all the logistics surrounding your trip
to ukraine who is involved in
coordinating each of your journeys
braden is my camera guy and my editor he
is with me all the time uh and uh and
and we do um all of our stories together
uh but there's also our ukrainian fixer
anna she you'll also see her often in my
stories as well because you know she's
such an integral part of of our
journalism it's you know the executive
team that is putting us there and making
sure that we have what we need and that
we have all of the the other little
pieces in place that we have security
that's you know we have the kit that we
need we have our network resources guy
mark blanchard who is integral in every
foreign assignment there's a lot of
moving parts and everyone sort of needs
to be
walking in the same direction at the
same time over multiple time zones and
multiple stories
you mentioned your fixer anna and the
work that she provides in terms of
translation but what else does a fixer
do and how did you link up with her
i uh found anna on one of my original
trips to ukraine even before the full
invasion um so a fixer is your your
local eyes and ears they do everything
from um you know help you with the
language to make sure you understand the
cultural implications to um you know
introducing you to people to helping you
you know get settled in your room to to
deal with different people in the
community so literally they are your
your shadow they're your avatar they are
you so you also really need to make sure
that you're linked up journalistically
and that they understand your
expectations and your standards so that
everybody can work together you're
speaking very matter-of-factly of all
the challenges that you face uh just in
terms of getting your your journalism
out to the world how do you put the
inherent danger of reporting in a war
zone out of your mind to do your job
effectively you can't and you shouldn't
that's my my personal view
you have to have a
i have to have a healthy respect and
understanding of the situation i know
i'm going to a conflict zone i know it's
dangerous um you have to kind of you
know
wrestle with that with your yourself and
your family and make sure that they know
that you're going and they're
comfortable with it too when i was back
in afghanistan reporting there were so
many great journalists that i that i got
to spend time with and one of the things
that they always said
and he's not with us in his anymore his
name is matthew fisher he he looked at
me and said you've got to remember your
gut and if something ever doesn't feel
right don't do it because your body will
tell you and i've always believed that
what is it like emotionally spending a
week covering the war in ukraine then
coming back to relatively normal life
in the uk there's this moment where
you're in ukraine and you kind of know
okay at any point in time something can
happen and you're aware of all of that
but then
in a flash you're in poland
and you're safe
and it's
it's literally just you know walking
across a border or the train crossing
over and then suddenly poof
that that fear that that pressure just
goes away and it it really messes with
your mind and it takes a little time to
sort of get back into that like normal
mentality of you know it's okay to hear
a plane fly by there's nothing else
that's going to happen crystal thank you
very much for your time today you've
done some fantastic work i know you are
have another deployment coming up in the
next few weeks thanks again and stay
safe
thanks so much mike